la parole est à notre collègue catherine
procaccia pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame touraine le 7
décembre
plus de 8000 étudiants en 6e année de
médecine ont participé à des épreuves
qui devaient leur permettre d'avoir un
aperçu de leur rende leur classement et
donc de la spécialité est de la ville
dans laquelle ils effectueraient leur
troisième cycle sur des tablettes
tactiles
une innovation il devait écouter le
souffle cardiaque analyses et des scans
il aurait dû car dans les 34 centres
universitaires
les épreuves ont été interrompu au bout
de 20 minutes
nos futurs médecins n'ont eu accès qu'à
des pdf les serveurs ayant été
immédiatement saturé certes ce sont des
futurs médecins mais pas des cobayes
il a pris si peu d'avoir participé à un
crash test
alors que ses premières épreuves et être
importante pour eux ils sont d'autant
plus inquiets que le centre national de
gestion chargé par votre ministère
d'organiser l'épreuve nationale
classante a tranquillement déclaré avoir
paramétré des serveurs pour cinq mille
connexions simultanées
alors qu'ils étaient huit mille inscrits
quel amateurisme comment est ce possible
ma question est simple quelles mesures
d'urgence et quelles garanties apportées
vous pour que les épreuves de juin se
déroule correctement pour vous répondre
la parole et à la ministre de la santé
droit des femmes d affaires sociales de
la parole madame toile ainsi monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame
la sénatrice pro cassia il y a plusieurs
années les représentants des étudiants
ont exprimé leur souhait que nous
allions vers un exam en classe un examen
classant national réalisé sur tablette
et non plus sur papier c'est pour
répondre à cette demande en lien avec
les doyens que thierry mandon et moi
même avons fait en sorte de mettre en
place un système qui doit permettre la
réalisation du premier examen sur
tablette au moins de juin prochain pour
préparer cet examen
des tests ont été réalisés le premier
test ya eu deux tests au mois de
décembre
ce ne sont pas des épreuves madame la
sénatrice je veux reprendre revenir là
dessus ce qui s'est passé au mois de
décembre est un test qui a planté entre
guillemets pour reprendre le vocabulaire
informatique
il y a eu un bug massif lors du premier
test et je comprends parfaitement
l'inquiétude et la préoccupation des
étudiants et des enseignants qui se
demandent ce qui va se passer mais dès
le lendemain un autre test a été réalisé
qui s'est déroulé dans de bonnes
conditions pour garantir la qualité des
examens du mois de juin prochain j'ai
indiqué que deux nouveaux tests seraient
réalisés au mois de février et au mois
de mars pour s'assurer que l'origine du
bug qui a eu lieu a bien été identifié
je veux donc vous dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'enjeu financier que l'ensemble des
services travaillent pour faire en sorte
que cet examen très important pour les
étudiants en médecine se déroule dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
merci à l'impro quotium merci vous
comprenez l'inquiétude de nos futurs
médecins et j'espère qu'ils l'apprécient
mais il aimerait vous croire parce que
cette réforme était quand même attendu
depuis longtemps
le cng et n'a commencé l'installation
d'un réseau spécifique au mois de
novembre alors que c'était pour moi
dette de décembre
comment quelle est la crédibilité des
annonces alors que le cng a osé répondre
que le système était performant et que
le problème était que les étudiants ne
se comportait pas comme leurs robes aux
testeurs et quand vous dites que le
lendemain les épreuves se sont bien
réalisés c'est inexact
même le troisième jour 40 % des
étudiants n'ont toujours pas eu accès à
l'informatique
cette échelle vous le savez d'autant mal
vécu qu'il vient après le vote de la loi
santé qui met à mal et futur métro
conclure et qui maintenant se surnomme
la génération test y at il au moins un
système un autre système de prévu si
l'intégralité plantes